in this video we'll talk about itaxia
telenjax this year this is for USMLE
step one and it's a high yield video
is one type of disorder that results in
decreased T and B cell activity
it actually stands for uncoordinated
movement and uncoordinated walking Gates
and telenjaxia refers to blood vessels
underneath the skin which looks like a
spider like vessel
so in Ataxia the common symptoms include
uncoordinated movement there is the part
that are affected in the body is the
brain especially the cerebellum
obviously the spider-like veins and
blood vessels are very much kind of like
common in this particular disease
the patients with Ataxia talenjaxia has
reduced B cell and T Cell numbers
and they are highly uh
susceptible to many infection
so this comes under one type of
immunodeficiency in this video we will
try to understand why T and B cells are
less in number or non-functional
okay let's talk about the clinical Triad
of ataxia so the clinical Triad includes
three things
cerebellar defects which is ataxia
spider angiomas which is the land
Jackson Shea and IGA deficiency so these
are the three important symptoms
remember always that cerebellum is the
particular portion which is essential
for motor coordination and when there is
a defect in cerebellum most likely it
would result in ataxia
IGA is a secreted version of antibody
and this is important for many immune
aspects and that is also deficient in
these patients
so let's talk about the biology behind
that whenever we have a double-stranded
DNA break in our genome it raises a kind
of like an alarm signal and this kind of
Damages are detected by kinases known as
ATM or ATR
so these kinases are actually double
strand brake sensors these kinases are
produced by specific genes
and whenever they find this kind of
double-stranded DNA break they prevent
the cell cycle and they kind of create a
pause in the cell cycle giving the cell
enough time to repair that brick and
then restart the cycle
obviously if there is a problem in the
sensing mechanism there could be problem
in overall aspect of the cell cycle
so ATM is actually encoded by a specific
Gene and in Ataxia thalenjax Shear this
particular Gene is mutated that means a
functional ATM product is not produced
as a result what happens
there is a failure to detect DNA damage
that result results in failure in
halting the progression of cell cycle
and that can cause
so many mutations in the genome
but what is the functional relation
between ATM mutation and developmental
defect in t or B cells why it is at all
necessary
let's understand that
so while B cells and T cells are
maturing they need to under their
receptors the B cell receptor and the T
Cell receptor need to undergo vdj
recombination vdj recombination is very
important for both T cells and B cells
and this is a recombination process
which requires double-stranded DNA break
and also repair machineries
if you want to learn more about vdjri
combination there is a video which is
linked in the I button or in the
description
also for B cell maturation there is an
another important step which is isotype
switching detailed video is again in the
I button but isotype switching produces
different variants of antibodies for
example by default IGM is the key
antibody isotype but eventually based on
the infection based on the cytokines
that are produced IGG IGA would be
produced
so isotype switching is key factor for B
cell maturation
but again isotype switching requires
this kind of specific recombination like
mechanism which requires DNA break
now in both vdj recombination and
isotype switching
double stranded DNA break formation is
really important and that has to be
sensed by ATM further repaired by repair
machinery
most of these cases the non-homologous
end joining Machinery detects this kind
of problems and fix that
but once ATM is mutated the sensor is
gone
and both these key essential processes
for B cell and T Cell development
is abrogated and that is why the patient
with 80 uh it actually has low level of
T cell and B cell count
so now we understand the biology of it
but let's talk about the clinical
features that we have to understand and
remember
so
in these patients there is a high level
of alpha phetoprotein
low level of IgA IGG or IG or any kind
of like isotype because isotype
switching doesn't happen in ataxia
also there is a lymphopenia cerebellar
atrophy I mean developmental defect of
the cerebellum
and also risk of lymphoma and Leukemia
is increased in these patients so I hope
this was useful if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up you can get
more notes and flashcards in our
Instagram or Facebook page do visit that
and please support our Channel using
super thanks see you in next video